welcome back to las vegas now it's time
to unlock the capriati's pro bowl prize
promo code rocky the question is are you
a pro
jillian i don't know okay we're about to
find out because since we're you know
doing this for the pro bowl it's only
right
you put me to the test to see if i can
actually join the capriati's team all
right you ready ben let's do this all
right tell me what i'm doing all right
so next we're going to make a bobby here
i want you to show me your skills okay
see if you're a pro with this
um and during this i'm also gonna be
asking a little football question as
well so a couple of those okay so if i
get these right this unlocks the promo
code that is true for you guys at home
to get a chance to win all of this for
your pro bowl party weekend okay all
right start with the tournament no don't
tell me i don't know okay my bad okay
i'm going ask me the question all right
so where is this year's pro bowl being
played allegiant okay good when was the
first pro bowl played oh come on i don't
know i don't know
where was last year's pro bowl played um
orlando good good okay all right so
bonus question to unlock it okay who is
playing in the super bowl this year
the bengals and the rooms yeah all right
that unlocks the code so if you download
our app you can go on there and uh
redeem an offer for all this great stuff
the code is going to be caps c-a-p-s
pb 22. did okay everybody did you hear
that the promo code is c-a-p-s-p-b-22
that's right for the pro bowl this
weekend that's a good-looking bobby is
this a good-looking bobby yeah that's a
good one jillian and jc said i need a i
need a sandwich named after me okay we
could call it the rocky for today okay
there we go and then jc we're sending
you back those bobby's right there buddy
i love it also you guys look at this
a bobby pillow bobby socks you can't go
wrong i mean how can you go wrong and if
you enter in this con in this contest
you guys can win all of this this
weekend but you have to enter
by friday on our app download the app on
the app store or google play store and
the code is caps c-a-p-s pb 22. whoa
this is so good okay question
you i know this is we're in summerlin
we're in downtown sunderland i know you
get pro athletes in here all the time
yep what do they order uh you know a lot
of people give me some names
oh no no i'm not gonna drop anybody but
they order the cheesesteak it's a
classic i'll go to everybody oh that's
actually on the screen right there as
well as our cold italian which is also
another go-to cold cut style
but we do have a lot of uh you know
golden knights come in here and uh a lot
of other athletes so we're very
fortunate for that and we love giving
back to the community i love it well
thank you so much ben last but not least
everybody pre-game
let's do a dance i saw you doing your
pre-game dance in your freaking stretch
let's see it teach me what is it you
know i'm gonna hit him with the
sprinkler real quick
and then we're gonna go shopping
shop shop put shop it that's the
pre-game day we're shopping i know
you're shopping for i'll get off the
show i like that shopping making
sandwiches yeah let's get it all right
provo this weekend we're ready we're
ready you guys make sure you download
the app enter to win all of this i'll
send it to you rocky's having too much
fun she's doing the sprinkler she's
making sandwiches she's doing football
trivia
thank you so much rocky jc i'll send it
over to you